Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich habe überlegt, wir könnten ja vielleicht mal unsere eigenen Schoko Videos produzieren.
Dazu habe ich im Kern eigentlich nichts zu sagen. Und wenn ich das gewusst hätte, hätte ich das äh rechtlich überprüfen lassen.
Ja, das internationale Podcast Marketing und Branding schreitet voran. Ja, also man muss einfach auch versuchen, auf allen Kanälen zu bespielen, man muss einfach,
Märkte besetzen, das gebietet der Kapitalismus und der Kapitalismus ist unsere Religion und wer will der Religion schon entsagen?
Ein Innovationsfreundliches Internet heißt, dass es eine bestimmte Sicherheit für Spezialdienste gibt. Wirklich. Mhm.
Wirklich. Das prescht jetzt schon ein bisschen voran. Hast du nicht auch den Eindruck.
Ich ich spreche voran. Wir wollen erstmal noch zurückpreschen. Denn es gab äh herrlich viele Kommentare zur letzten Sendung.
Ja, hast du sie gezählt.
Nee, weiß ich nicht. Ich zähle das nicht. Ich äh gefühlt viele,
in denen äh darauf hingewiesen wurde, äh dass Google ja mit seinen anderen Diensten auch Geld verdiene.
Ja.
Ja? Und da erinnere ich mich jetzt leider nicht. Äh vielleicht habe ich da aber auch einen kurzen Ausfall meiner Wahrnehmungskraft gehabt, äh dass ich behauptet hätte, Google würde mit diesen anderen Diensten kein Geld verdienen. Der Punkt ist,
Deswegen, das ist das, was ich versucht habe, da so ausführlich zu erklären in den Ausführungen, dass Google eine Markt beherrschende Stellung ausnutzt und nicht, womit sie Geld verdient.
Sie äh sie könnten auch Gmail als Kosten äh pflichtigen Dienst
dort anbringen. Es geht um die Ausnutzung ihrer Markt beherrschenden Stellungen nicht darum, womit sie Geld verdienen und womit nicht.
Das ist glaube ich das, was letzte Woche ähm mich nicht gut genug erklärt habe, als dass es alle hätten verstehen können.
Also haben wir das jetzt hier nochmal klargestellt,
Auch nochmal klarstellen sollten wir, wo äh der tolle Treck herkam, den wir am Ende der letzten Sendung mentallos eingeworfen haben. Wie es so unsere Art ist.
Genau das war, das war der äh das war der Bonustrack von der Cyber Cyber EP, die unser guter Arne jetzt endlich veröffentlicht hat.
Genau
Und zwar ist das sozusagen, ihr erinnert euch an die Cyber Cyber Folge, dass ja dann äh dieses großartige äh Stück nach sich zog und Anna hat fleißig äh gearbeitet da in den letzten Wochen und hat
jetzt quasi so eine komplette EP auf Soundcloud releast. Alles schön frei zum Runterladen
Und äh es gibt dann halt auch noch so einen feinsten Remix, der jetzt hier vielleicht so ein bisschen das Programm springen würde, aber da könnt ihr einfach selber mal hinterher klicken. Cyber, Cyber sozusagen in der Extended äh äh Edition
tanzbar. Ich äh bin schon sehr gespannt, wie das dann auf dem einunddreißig C drei auf dem Dancefloor abgeht.
Und das äh Stück aus der letzten Woche war der Cyber Cyber Le Dub. Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage und da möchte ich äh da gibt's jetzt was zu gewinnen, nämlich einen Haufen ähm Nerdpunkte.
Ärger. Punkte. Ach so, ne.
Ähm die der Tim nämlich nicht bekommen hat, das kann ich schon mal dazu sagen. Ähm und zwar, woher kommt diese Melodie?
Von dem. Das ist jetzt für die Hörer, Tim, die habe ich's ja schon gesagt. Wer wer der erste Kommentar, der weiß, äh woher diese Melodie kommt, darf sich einen Artikel von meiner Wunschliste aussuchen und an mich schicken.
Nein, das ist nein, aber es ist schon klar, das ist schon klar, dass man da jetzt einfach mal, wer das als erstes kommentiert hat
erstens als erstes die Folge gehört, zweitens weiß er, wer die Melodie kommt und das kann man dann auch schon mal irgendwie editieren. Da mache ich, weiß nicht, ähm editiere ich den Kommentar und mache die Schrift rot oder so. Da gibt's irgendeinen kleinen Bonus oder wir machen so einen animierten Schnee oder einen Nikolaus oben drauf oder so. Das ist schon ähm,
wenn wenn hier ne der ganze rumrennt und sagt er wär der Papst, das nicht weiß, ne, da kann man doch wohl so ein so eine Hörerin.
Ich renne nicht rum und sage, ich bin der Papst. Was denn? Ich bin der Pate.
Nein, du sagst hier die ganze Zeit Neo, wie heißt das nochmal, was du da immer machst? Diese Religion.
Sagt, wir sind alle Päpste. Du auch.
Aber du bist der Einzige, der damit angibt. Was? Ja.
Was? Ich gebe da überhaupt nicht mit an. Ich ich verteile nur die Gunst weiter und das ist ja auch das Recht jedes Diskredias das genauso zu tun und dazu möchte ich auch anhalten.
Also wer wer ähm,
der erste, der erste Kommentar in den Kommentaren zu dieser Sendung, der sagt, woher diese Melodie kommt, wird von Tim dem Papst höchstpersönlich zum, zu einem weiteren Papst,
unter uns allen.
Wer auch immer als erstes kommentiert wird zur Rechtschaft gezogen. So sieht's nämlich aus.
Aber ich möchte trotzdem, dass es also so dokumentiert ist wieder niemand.
Jetzt habe ich so ein bisschen äh FUT geschaffen, ne. Wie man so schön sagt.
Eine Schokolade ist auch leer. Nee, wir können da nicht mehr bieten als Ehre und Papsttum.
Da, genau. Also er oder sie, die irgendwie vorsprechen, gönnt sich Gummipunkte abholen. Wolltest du zum Inhalt kommen?
Unbedingt sein muss.
Ausnahmsweise. Ja, wir äh schalten um zur Bundesregierung. Die Bundesregierung, die weiß ja, was sie will.
Genau. Die Bundes.
Verwandelt, manchmal das Gefühl hat, dass sie nicht so genau weiß, wovon eigentlich die Rede ist,
Oder? Na ja, auf jeden Fall hat sich Angela Merkel ähm gemeldet und ähm das äh,
der Vodafone Konferenz zum Thema Netzneutralität, wie denn das so sei mit der Bundesregierung und der Netzneutralität,
Äh kein geringerer als,
Mister Obama. Hat sich ja auch zu dem Thema vor kurzem geäußert und äh auch wenn man da zwischen den Zeilen sicherlich das ein oder andere noch herauspicken kann im Wesentlichen eigentlich so Netzneutralität als solche in Reinform angemahnt,
oder habe ich da was verpasst.
Obama hat gesagt, er möchte Netzneutralität in Reinform
und äh sofort und er wird da alles für tun und er hängt da jetzt seine seine Präsident sie dran und nix mit irgendwie Quatsch oder so, sondern keine Hintertüren, sondern freies offenes Internet
vor ein oder zwei Wochen. Wir hatten das hier äh gewürdigt,
und jetzt ist ja so, dass äh die Bundesrepublik Deutschland gerade auch an dieser Snowdendebatte immer den Eindruck macht, sich nicht ausreichend von den USA zu emanzipieren. Ja? Und wenn man da mal so eine Möglichkeit hat, ähm,
sich,
von den USA abzugrenzen, ja? Und dafür so richtig schön auch Applaus von der heimischen Industrie zu bekommen, dann darf man so eine Gelegenheit natürlich nicht verstreichen lassen. Und ähm,
wo wäre die Gelegenheit besser als bei einer Vodafone-Konferenz, ja? Man muss sich ja auch erstmal den richtigen Rahmen suchen für so eine vollmundige Ankündigung. Dann äh zu sagen,
Anstelle von Angela Merkel persönlich,
Innovationsfreundliches Internet heißt, dass es eine bestimmte Sicherheit für Spezialdienste gibt und weiter. Wenn sie das fahrerlose Auto fahren wollen.
Oder wenn sie bestimmte,
telemedizinische Anwendung haben, dann müssen sie natürlich eine fehlerfreie und immer gesicherte Übertragung haben,
Ja, das betont Angela Merkel. Bei einer Vodafone-Konferenz. Wir wissen ja, dass fahrerlose Autos steht unmittelbar bevor,
und die Telemedizin ist ja auch äh ne, wir sehen täglich kommen irgendwie Leute unters Messer äh äh um ums Leben, weil die Telemedizin irgendwie äh ruckelt, ne? Und.
Das ist der Gedanke, so etwas, so etwas,
sowas etwas betriebskritisches und Hochrisiko behaftetes, wie das Operieren von jemandem oder das Führen eines Fahrzeugs, ja?
Fahre los, also eine Fern spricht ja hier von einer Fernsteuerung und nicht von einem autonomen Betrieb, was sowieso vollkommen absurd ist, ja,
Dass das nur zu haben wäre, wenn man im Internet da äh spezielle Dienste einführt.
Naja, also das das Fahrer, das die, die, die wohl im Moment am,
Ich bin nicht besonders äh fit, was diese ähm oder besonders auf dem aktuellsten Stand, was diese autonomen,
oder hier richtig als Fahrer los beschriebenen Fahrzeuge angeht, aber natürlich hat Google da in sehr schneller Zeit ähm sehr große Fortschritte gemacht bei Fahrzeugen, die tatsächlich auf ähm,
Auf deren Diensten beruhen. Das heißt, dass Fahrzeug ist nicht mehr autonom oder nicht mehr nur autonom und hat eine Kamera und ähm,
versucht ihr unten Radar und was nicht alles für Sensoren und versucht irgendwie festzustellen, was um es herum los ist, sondern,
bekommt außerdem noch
allerlei Informationen aus dem äh aus dem Äther von Google selber. Nämlich zum Beispiel wie fahren alle anderen Autos, wo wo ist ein Stau und so weiter. Ne, also einmal alles. Das heißt, dass wenn du sagst, du willst ein fahrerloses Auto haben, dann ist das per,
Einfach grundsätzlich wird das noch besser fahren, wenn es sich gleichzeitig auch nochmal mit dem Internet ähm abgleicht, ja. Was es aber natürlich nicht.
Soweit erstmal eine Behaupt.
Nee, da bin ich mir absolut sicher in jedem Bereich. Wenn du äh wenn du einhundert ähm einzelne Fahrzeuge baust oder ähm einhundert die am Ende über ein System vernetzt sind,
dann wird dieses wird diese zweite Möglichkeit die bessere sein. Weil es zum Beispiel ein eines der größten Probleme
Ganz einfach löst, nämlich dieses zwei Autos oder zwei fahrerlose Autos auf Kollisionskurs, in welche Richtung ähm biegen sie ab?
Ne? Das ist ja also so, in welche Richtung weichen sie aus. Ähm und das könntest du jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn wenn du einfach das kollektive
das kollektive Gehirn aller Fahrzeuge bist, dann kannst du halt alle möglichen ähm Störfaktoren durch das Verhalten des anderen Fahrzeugs ähm,
auslassen. Das heißt, es werden nicht mehr einhundert Autos einzeln gesteuert, sondern,
Eigentlich steuert eine mega Intelligenz einhundert Fahrzeuge. Und das funktioniert auf jeden Fall immer besser. Deswegen.
Fern alle Fahrzeuge von derselben Intelligenz gesteuert werden, insofern die Intelligenz auch in der Lage ist, mit der Realität klarzukommen, weil es ist ja nicht so, dass zentral alle relevanten Informationen vorliegen und dass eben viele Sachen auch nicht so ohne weiteres entscheidbar sind. Also ich halte das alles für Mumpitz.
Das ist sehr schön, aber dann ähm möchte ich Tos trotzdem noch ausführen, weil ich mir dessen relativ sicher bin, weil du noch den weiteren Vorteil hast, dass du pro Fahrzeug
sehr viel weniger Rechenleistung an Bord haben muss, das heißt selbst also ein ein wirklich autonomes Fahrzeug, was sich im Straßenverkehr vor allem dann noch gemischt mit anderen
unvorhersagbar wahnsinnig fahrenden Fahrzeugen von Menschen bewegen soll,
da hättest du quasi allein schon schon Ausriss, Ressourcen ähm Schonungsansprüchen,
'n klaren Anreiz da Teile des der Intelligenz dieses Fahrzeugs auszulagern. Also dass diese Fahrzeuge übers Internet mit einer Zentralen Instanz verbunden werden sollten.
Und in dem System, was sich in der Zukunft durchsetzen wird, auch werden, es äh steht ähm absolut außer Frage. Was aber
sehr stark in Frage steht, ist, ob diese Fahrzeuge in Echtzeit mit dem Internet verbunden sein müssen und ob sie in der Tat stehen bleiben, wenn sie mal keine äh wenn sie mal gerade keine Bits bekommen.
Ja, so baust du so ein System natürlich nicht. Das ist ja auch nicht so, als bräuchte dein, als würde dein Google Maps irgendwie heute stehen bleiben,
wenn äh wenn du mal irgendwie kurz durch ein Funkloch fährst, der hat ja dann schon seine Informationen vorgecasht, weil diese Fahrzeuge natürlich, wenn du ein äh wenn du irgendwie ein Gerät baust, was mit einer sehr hohen Geschwindigkeit über die Straße rauscht, dann ähm,
machst du das nicht in echtzeitabhängig, sondern schickst dem halt sehr, sehr viele oder möglichst viel ähm,
Wissen, was es benötigen könnte schon voraus,
Also ähm dass jetzt autonome Fahrzeuge tatsächlich an den Punkt kommen, dass sie eine garantierte,
Bandbreite zu jeder Zeit haben müssen ist erstens,
sowieso unwahrscheinlich, weil es ein sehr, sehr starke konzeptionelle Schwäche dieser Fahrzeuge wäre, wenn es so wäre.
Und zweitens wird es sowieso nochmal zwei, drei Jahrzehnte dauern und wäre heute noch kein Grund ähm,
die Netznetralität aufzulösen. Ähnliches gilt natürlich ähm,
bei diesen Fernos, wo ja wo die wo die Idee ja jetzt schon sein sollte, dass der der fernoperierende Arzt, der intelligenter ist und nicht der Google,
Trotzdem sind diese Systeme, müssen diese Systeme natürlich auch gegen äh Ausfall äh geschützt sein, ja und auch also allein,
die Idee, das Netzneutralität jetzt das am Ende tatsächlich behindern würde, ist ja ähm totaler Unsinn.
Ja, weil ich meine, wenn man so so einen Telemedizin macht, dann nimmt man da ohnehin dedizierte Leitungen, die nicht Internet sind.
Genau. Ich weiß aber äh also da das, das ohnehin.
Ja, das wäre wahrscheinlich auch bei den Autos auch so, weil ich meine, selbst wenn man eine gewisse Intelligenz noch irgendwie ins Netz verlagert, dann sicherlich nicht Seeopening Internet. Also alleine aus.
Ist ja genau das, wovon sie hier reden. Sie reden ja hier ähm nehmen.
Weiß, dass sie davon reden, aber das macht die Sache ja dann eben auch genauso absurd, äh dass dass das jetzt Argumente sein sollen, dafür, dass man eben Netzneutralität nicht durchhalten kann.
Wovon sie hier sprechen ist ähm und ähm was auch immer du heute wählt oder ähm,
oder landesweit erreichen möchtest mit irgendwie nennenswerter Bandbreite, erreichst du über
Mobilfunknetze. Und was nicht passieren wird ist, dass ähm dass die hingehen und noch ein komplett separates eigenes äh Mobilfunknetz bauen für diese Autos. Das heißt, sie werden die,
Sie würden, wenn sie sagen, sie bauen etwas, was nicht Internet ist. Das Mobilfunknetz nutzen,
Aus dessen Datenübertragungsstandard etwas auskapseln und das wäre genau Specialized Service.
Was insofern okay wäre, als dass ja dann das, was für Internet benutzt wird, immer noch für alle gleich wäre.
Ähm sofern.
Du den Specialized Service tatsächlich so definierst, ne? Und das gibt ja, es gibt ja dann einzelne Definitionen von Specialist Service, wo man sagt, ja, du kannst sogar diesen ähm,
Du kannst sogar diese letzte Meile irgendwie noch für irgendwas anderes nutzen, aber,
das darf dann eben kein Dienst sein, der über das normale Internet auch verfügbar wäre.
Also du hast einen DSL-Anschluss zu Hause, der du hast von der Telekom dreißig Mbit und du hast äh zwanzig MBit garantiert, ähm,
für deine Fern-OPs.
Aber diese Fern-OPs bieten bietet dir nicht Skype an, sondern dein äh was weiß ich, dein ich bin kein Internet, sondern ein digitaler Anschluss ähm wie ISDN oder was auch immer,
ähm über den du kommunizierst,
Das ist aber natürlich nicht das, wohin sie möchte, denn sie möchte natürlich und das ist eigentlich das Lustige, da sieht man, da sieht man eigentlich die gesamte Tragik,
Wir sind ja überhaupt nicht in der in der Nähe dessen, dass wir genug Bandbreite hätten, um auch nur annähernd ähm zwanzig oder zehn Prozent Google-Autos auf unseren Straßen rumfahren zu können,
weil die ja ähm weil weil unsere Bandbreite ja heute schon für nichts ausreicht. Das heißt, ähm.
Und das ist,
Genau, du sagst es, es gibt keine Bandbreite, das ist dann immer deine. Ähm und sie sagt dann, äh Angela Merkel sagt auch, wir brauchen uns über Netzneutralität nicht zu unterhalten,
Wenn die Kapazitäten nicht zur Verfügung stehen. Das ist ein sehr schöner Satz, weil,
Genau in dem Fall musst du dich über Netznetralität unterhalten.
Genau.
Und wenn die Kapazitäten zur Verfügung stehen,
Dann brauchst du dich nicht mehr unbedingt über Netznetralität zu unterhalten, weil es dann diese Frage nicht mehr gibt. Ja, also dieser Satz ist genau falsch, ja? Also wenn du ein Kapazitätsproblem hast, fängst du an, an die Netzneutralität ranzugehen,
um nämlich etwas mit deinem Netz noch umzusetzen, was eigentlich gar nicht mehr geht,
und wenn du kein Kapazitätsproblem hast, dann stellen sich auch alle diese Fragen der Netzneutralität nicht mehr,
Weil es dann einfach selbstverständlich ist.
Genau, wobei Kapazität jetzt nicht so ein Zustand an einem Ort ist, sondern es betrifft natürlich alle Kapazitäten, die Kapazitäten sowohl im Beckboden, als auch die Kapazitäten im Interconnect, als auch die Kapazitäten zu den äh,
Anschlüssen.
Genau und die einzigen, die immer nicht ausbauen, sind die am Ende, die äh die Anschlüsse. Also das Internet selber ist äh weit davon entfernt, irgendwo voll zu sein. Aber,
ähm die Provider, die den letzten, die die letzten Meter machen, die natürlich dann auch die teuersten sind, die und die,
hintern uns, ihre monatlichen Rechnungen schreiben. Das sind diejenigen,
den ihr Geschäft inzwischen nicht mehr lukrativ genug ist und die deswegen jetzt äh so ein so ein Quatsch daherreden, ja? Und das wenn also man merkt ja schon, weißt du, wenn und ich denke, da muss man,
hier viel mehr drauf gehen, als jetzt irgendwie sich mit mit fahrerlosen Autos auseinandersetzen. Die wenigsten von uns haben überhaupt schon ein fahrerloses Fahrzeug gesehen,
Wir wissen, dass es noch irgendwo zwischen zehn und zwanzig Jahren äh dauern wird, bis die hier tatsächlich rumfahren.
Die wenigsten von uns haben irgendwo bisher Berührungen mit der Telemedizin gemacht. Man sieht also, dass das zwei ähm.
Gegenwartsfremde Beispiele sind, die unsere gute Frau Merkel da jetzt anführt, während,
ähm Spotify bevorzugen im ähm
Telekomnetz und diese MTV äh Musicflat bevorzugen im E-Plus Netz und
gratis Facebook im E plus net und gratis Wikipedia in Hasse nicht gesehen. Das sind sehr konkrete Beispiele aus unserer,
Gegenwart und die haben natürlich auch alle mit Kapazitäten nichts zu tun, sondern mit weiteren Einnahmequellen für Provider,
und das ist natürlich der Punkt, der äh der hier eigentlich die gute Frau Merkel sprechen lässt, dass sie nämlich die Pistole auf der Brust hat, dass sie die Provider einfach sagen, ja, wir haben kein Geld, um die Netze auszubauen und dieses Land wird vor die Hunde gehen.
Und das ist das, wodurch diese Frau dazu gebracht wird, hier in die große Sprüche von von Zukunft zu sprechen,
weil eben die Infrastruktur, die uns das Internet bringen soll, auf den letzten Metern, wird dummerweise in privater Hand haben und dass Leute sind, auf die Angela Merkel nur noch sehr wenig ähm Einfluss nehmen kann,
dass sie denen möglichst nach dem Mund redet, offenbar, sonst würde sie aber.
Im Mobilfunkbereich, im Festnetzbereich sieht das sehr anders aus. Da sehe ich das Problem eher mit einer zu starken Kontrolle.
Ja, aber also Mobilfunk ist ja nun mal das, was weiß ja, dieses mit den Kabeln.
Setz dich nicht durch oder was?
Das setzt Tim, du natürlich würden würden das, das, also
Das setzt sich als Privatanschluss mittelfristig nicht durch. Was passieren wird, ist, dass die ähm,
dass die Provider früher oder später, das tun sie in einigen Ländern jetzt auch schon
diese Kabel, die sie jetzt bis zu dir nach Hause gelegt haben, sich immer mehr aneignen werden für ihren Kabelloskram. Das heißt, da sitzen, da werden dann
ähm du sitzt dann bei dir zu Hause, an deiner Fritzbox, die kann dann nicht nur W-Lan, sondern die kann auch noch ein zweites WLAN für,
die Hotspot Nutzer und für das Offload aus auf was LTE zum Beispiel schon kann oder an deinem
an deiner ähm Fritzbox äh steckt da noch so ein äh eine Femtozelle dran, die dann halt Teil des äh des Mobilfunknetzes des jeweiligen Providers ist, ja. Sowas, das ist ja auch schon üblich in anderen Ländern. Frankreich heißt das zum Beispiel schon ganz klar,
setzt dir eine Kiste hin, die macht ein offenes und macht dein WLAN, wie du das haben willst, die gibt einen Teil der Kapazität ab
all an die zahlenden Hotspot-Nutzer dieses Unternehmens und dann kannst du dir da noch eine Fermentozelle dranstecken und dann macht die noch zwei G3G und eine 4G wird dann sicherlich auch bald kommen
ne? Das heißt, dieser Teil wird der jetzt grade noch bei uns in die in die Wohnung läuft.
Und den wir irgendwie als unseren DSL-Anschluss sehen. Den werden die sich natürlich auch immer mehr aneignen, um halt nicht so weit äh funkende äh kleinere Zellen eben zu bauen.
Eben äh Femtozellen äh nennt sich das dann im Mobilfunkbereich. Und ähm die, wie gesagt, im LTE hast du dann auch schon so was drin, dass die dass die dass die LTE-Geräte auch über ein Wifi dann sprechen können.
Und dann hast du irgendwann so dieses überall gegenwärtige Netz. Das.
Am Ende aber keine nennenswerte Kapazität mehr aufweist und komplett hinterherhängt, was.
Nee, nee, das stimmt ja nicht, das stimmt ja nicht, dadurch, dass du, dass du ähm einen großen Teil durch diese Femtozellen und äh Wifi äh Spots,
auf andere Infrastruktur legst, als die, die zu den, zu den Funkmasten geht. Hast du ja tatsächlich auch einen Kapazitätszuwachs.
Provider aber nicht, der User und davon rede ich.
Klar, dem User, dem User gibt man das nicht, nein, nein, nein. Dem User gibt man dann halt ähm,
Facebook gratis und eingeschränkte Internetleistung damit er mehr bezahlen muss. Das ist natürlich das also sorry da muss man jetzt gerade einmal technische Entwicklung und Geschäftsmodellentwicklung äh nochmal getrennt halten, ja.
Am Ende wird hier keiner mehr irgendwie einen vernünftigen Internetanschluss haben. Am Ende werden wir alle ähm,
oder ja, am Ende werden wir alle relativ,
relativ eingeschränkte äh Konnektivität, dafür aber überall haben.
Technische und wirtschaftliche Entwicklung gerade. Das Traurige ist also ähm,
Angela Merkel hat offensichtlich nicht verstanden, was Netzneutralität ist und möchte jetzt für ein freies Netz und Spezialdienste kämpfen, denn
diese beiden Seiten muss man zusammenbringen und ich glaube, dass uns das in den Verhandlungen in Brüssel in kurzer Zeit gelingen kann.
Ja. Der Vodafone-Chef äh Jens Schultebockum, der sie da offensichtlich eingeladen hatte, ähm
betonte dann auch Echtzeitangebote, brauchen eine gesicherte Übertragungsqualität, für die sollen die Kunden gefälligst extra zahlen und sagt dann, wir brauchen sozusagen Verkehrsregeln,
weil Produkte unterschiedliche Anforderungen haben. Das ist auch schon wieder so ein so ein völliger Unsinn, ja, also der weiß ja auch, dass das mit Verkehrsregeln überhaupt nichts zu tun hat, ja,
ähm,
aber das ist grade eben das das Moderne, der moderne Ansatz, alles über Verkehrsregeln zu erklären und man kommt da ja auch gut mit zurecht, ne? Verkehrs äh hier IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, Sicherheitsgurt und alle sitzen da und sagen, ja Mensch, super, endlich.
Macht mal einer was gegen die ganzen Leute, äh die durch die ähm Windschutzscheibe wandern.
Ja, äh zu dem zu dem Argument, wie also zu dem Aspekt, wie,
zukunftsfern und fremd diese Aussage über autonomes Fahren ist, kann ich auch nochmal selber einen kleinen Podcast pluggen,
nämlich grade veröffentlicht habe. Forschergeist Nummer drei beschäftigt sich nämlich mit dem autonomen Verkehr, beziehungsweise auch mit diesen,
Fragen, die damit zusammenhängen, das haben wir eben schon so am Rande mit angerissen. Also grad dein Beispiel mit zwei Autos fahren aufeinander zu, ja, da gibt's diese reine technische Ebene,
Wie können diese Autos verhindern, nichts zusammenzustoßen? Weil dann gibt's da noch so eine ethische Ebene dahinter,
Wäre es nicht besser mit dem anderen Auto zusammenzustoßen, damit ich nicht die Fußgängergruppe da hinten überfahre. Und das sind halt alles so Entscheidungen.
Das sind alles Entscheidungen, die du besser triffst, wenn also
einfaches Beispiel, wenn diese Entscheidung von jedem der beiden Fahrzeuge einzeln getroffen wird, dann haben die beide nur das, was sie sehen. Wenn du aber jetzt ein Google allmächtigen Fahrzeugkontrolleur hast, mit dem die übers Internet reden, dann kannst du die Entscheidung
basierend auf der doppelten Anzahl Sensoren treffen. Und deswegen macht es Sinn, diese Fahrzeuge alle untereinander zu vernetzen.
Erinnert aber nichts an den ethischen Fragen. Also ob das nun zentral oder dezentral äh gemacht wird. Du hast, du hast da einfach immer ein eine Vielzahl von Abwägungen und äh einfach Problematiken,
einfach über die technische Problematik weithin ausgehen. Also das ist wirklich kein Thema für zwanzig vierzehn.
Nee, das sowieso nicht, aber die die technischen Fragen äh bin ich mir trotzdem sicher, hier äh sinnvoll beantwortet zu haben.
Ja
Nicht. Wenn ich dich, wenn ich dich mit meinem äh mit meinem autonomen Fahrzeug nicht überfahren kann, dann kaufe ich das nicht.
Also,
Meinetwegen kannst du die These mit Zentrale besser und man hat ja mehr Daten andererseits äh kannst du mir gerne mitkommen. Andererseits äh sehe ich das nicht unbedingt als gesichert an,
und äh Autonomie heißt eben auch in einem Grad her über die eigenen Daten und äh die Aussagelogiken dadrüber zu sein, bis man überhaupt so etwas auf die Welt loslassen will.
Na dann, dann wird es, dann wird die, dann wird die gleiche Entscheidung halt aus reiner äh
Ressourcen, Sparsamkeit getroffen, weil man kein äh kein Geld hat, die Autos so teuer zu machen, dass in jedem einen Hochleistungsrechner steckt. Und ähm die Leute, die nicht kaufen und der Hochleistungsrechner zu viel Strom braucht.
Dann wird das eben der Grund sein, warum.
Ja, ich glaube, ohne äh Hochleistungsrechner wird das eh nix werden. Egal, das müssen wir jetzt nicht hier entscheiden. Ich wollte ja eigentlich auch nur die Gelegenheit nutzen, um hier schamlos meinen Podcast zu ploggen.
So sieht's nämlich aus Tim und da wollte ich jetzt möglichst drüber hinwegtäuschen.
Nicht geschafft.
Na, wer weiß? Ich wusste gar nicht, dass du einen neuen Podcast machst. Forschergeist, weil ähm mit wem machst du den denn? Horizonte für Bildung und Forschung.
Genau, ist eine Auftragsarbeit für den Städter Verband und da geht's um Wissenschaft im Allgemeinen,
Also wer die Organisation von Wissenschaft. Und äh das wird ein recht bunter Strauß und das hat jetzt grade mal thematisch gut gepasst.
Äh ist Folge zwei, Geschichte der Wissenschaften ist Folge eins und null ist die Vorstellung des Konzeptes. Sehr interessant, freut mich, weil ich nämlich gerade neue Podcasts suche.
Eingefunden.
Ja. Ich hatte letztens noch einen gefunden, aber der war gar nicht so gut, den habe ich wieder abbestellt.
Oder von mir? Nee. Dann bist ja beruhigt.
Nee. Nein, der war von ähm.
Sag's nicht. Lass uns weiter äh marschieren. Bundesregierung Teil zwei.
Ja, ah das ist auch geil. Das ist schön. Also ähm,
Eine der großen Fragen des äh NSA Untersuchungsausschusses ist ja setzt man Snowden,
durch eine Einladung vor Ort, ja, eine persönliche Einladung nach vor Ort, dem Risiko einer Auslieferung aus. Oder welchem Risiko setzt man ihn überhaupt aus?
Und da gab es jetzt aus dem NSA Untersuchungsausschuss husch schon vor einiger Zeit, vor mehreren Monaten eine Anfrage an das Bundesjustiz Justizministerium unter unserem guten Freund Heiko Maas von der SPD,
und zwar bat man ihn dabei, mal wieder um Amtshilfe in Form der Herausgabe eines Schreibens des US-Department of Justice, also des US-amerikanischen Justizministeriums.
Und in diesem Schreiben ähm ging man da von diesem Schreiben vermutete man, dass es Bezug auf eine mögliche Auslieferung Snowdens nehme,
Und zwar wollte man aus, bei hoffte man sich, dadurch, dass man dieses Schreiben in seine Hände bekommt, welche,
Vorwürfe,
in den USA eigentlich dem guten Edward Snowden gemacht werden und aufgrund welcher Straftaten oder aufgrund welcher vorgeworfenen Straftaten man denn eine auf eine Auslieferung hinarbeiten würde.
Würde man ja meinen, dass so eine Argumentation vorliegt.
Genau und das tut sie auch, denn die äh Bundesregierung äh oder der gute Heiko Maas hat dieses Dokument dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss
nicht zugänglich gemacht. Erstmal war Monate lang Schweigen im Walde
da hat er einfach gar nicht drauf reagiert, wenn dann irgendwann äh wurde geantwortet, ja also die Beantwortung, die der Frage, ob Herr Sorden an die USA ausgeliefert werden kann,
Ist nicht zwangsläufig erforderlich für die Klärung der Sachverhalte, für die der Untersuchungsausschuss eingesetzt wurde.
Ach. Das ist ja eine super äh Formulierung. Ist ja erstmal eine Behauptung, würde ich sagen, ne, die sich äh vor allem auch relativ schlecht halten lässt.
Ja, das ist schon ziemlich ähm,
Ziemlich dreist, ne? Ist ja auch so eine ähm so eine, da verbirgt sich ja sogar so eine richtige Zurechtweisung drin, ne, zu sagen, ja. Also, hör mal, das ist doch überhaupt nicht eure Aufgabe, euch damit zu befassen. Ähm,
Und äh das gebe ich euch nicht. Also mit anderen Worten, sie haben sich wieder irgendeinen beknackten Grund ausgedacht und ähm
wollen dieses Dokument nicht rausgeben. Der der Hintergrund ist natürlich klar, wenn sie dieses Dokument wirklich rausgeben, dann wäre der Welt bekannt, ähm was Edwards Norden vorgeworfen wird und ähm,
dann könnte Edwards Norden und seine Anwälte sicher auch irgendwie darauf äh darauf einstellen. Das darf ja weder äh äh Julian Assange,
noch etwas wirklich,
Bei Julian Assange weiß ja auch nicht, ob oder was ihm in den USA äh vorgeworfen würde, wenn man äh seines,
Körpers habhaft würde. Ja, die sollen ja auch genau in dieser äh Angst bleiben
und ich denke, dass es auch gezielt so, dass sowas aus der Öffentlichkeit herausgehalten wird, damit du nicht nachher noch äh juristische ähm Haarspalterei hast, ähm die eventuell den Druck von dieser Person nimmt, ne.
Ja, ich meine, die haben alle ihren Kafka gelesen, würde ich sagen, ne.
Die haben alle ihren Kafka gelesen und wussten, was man machen muss. Der linken Abgeordnete Andre Hahn,
sah dann zurecht in der Ablehnung eine erneute und nicht hinnehmbare Brustierung des gesamten Untersuchungsausschusses durch die Bundesregierung und kündigte an, dass er in der nächsten Ausschusssitzung beantragen wird,
dass dieser nunmehr als Gremium eine Klage gegen die Bundesregierung auf Herausgabe der Unterlagen ähm einreicht.
Ich finde das überhaupt geil, dass sozusagen die die befragte Partei,
sich anmaßt, also ich meine, es gibt so eine relativ konkrete Anfrage so. Hey, äh übrigens, wir hätten hier gerne mal eine Information, weil dann können wir besser unsere Arbeit irgendwie machen. Da hätten würden wir gerne mal Schlüsse draus ziehen. Und die Antwort ist mehr so ein,
Ach, das wollt ihr gar nicht. Und ähm das braucht ihr gar nicht und überhaupt was fällt euch ein äh überhaupt zu fragen? Ich freue mich wiederum, mit welchem Recht kann sich eigentlich diese Bundesregierung an dieser Stelle eine eine Aussage Verweigerung überhaupt,
leisten, also auf welcher Grundlage kann die überhaupt so eine Aussage tätigen, dass das nicht relevant ist für die Arbeit des Ausschusses? Ich meine, ist das nicht die,
Ist das nicht die Sache des Ausschusses, selber dadrüber zu befinden, was für sie relevant ist oder nicht? Ich meine, wird ja nicht genau deshalb eingesetzt.
Er sagt halt sehr spezifisch, die Beantwortung der Frage, ob Herr Snowden an die USA ausgeliefert werden kann, ist nicht
zwangsläufig, nicht zwangsläufig erforderlich für die Klärung der Sachverhalte, für die der Untersuchungsausschuss eingesetzt wurde. Der soll ja aufklären.
Ja, aber wo steht denn das etwas zwangsläufig erforderlich sein muss? Es ist auch so, auch wenn der Ausschuss der Meinung ist, dass es vielleicht erforderlich ist oder möglicherweise erforderlich oder möglicherweise sinnvoll wäre, diese Information.
Einfach nur vielleicht mal auch interessant.
Ja, ich meine, vor allem man weiß ja eigentlich auch vorher gar nicht, ob eine Information für einen relevant ist oder nicht.
Das sagt aber der Heiko Maas doch jetzt. Na du. Er ist Minister. Der ist Minister.
Und der ist Minister, der der hat was gelernt, ja. Der, der ist auch der ist der hat sowas gebracht, der ist in der Bundesregierung.
Kummer, der hat sechs Monate gebraucht, um diesen einen Satz zu schreiben, der wird jetzt schon ganz genau wissen, warum er dir das nicht gibt. Vertraue da doch mal der, der macht, Junge.
Ich sehe schon im Innenministerium, da haben die da wahrscheinlich wirklich so.
Justizministerium.
Justizministerin, genau, da haben sie so so richtige äh Spezialisten, ja, die klöppeln und feilen,
kneten an so einem Satz einfach monatelang. Ist wahrscheinlich so ein spezieller Stahl äh verschlossener Trakt, so ein Hochsicherheitstrakt, so ähnlich wie das Designstudio bei Apple. Da kommt man nicht so ohne weiteres rein,
Da werden dann einfach die Sätze für die Ewigkeit gemacht.
Und dann kommt irgendwann der Heiko Maas raus und sagt neuen Satz oder was.
Genau. Hier.
Na ja, okay, also.
Ich habe euch einen neuen Satz gebracht.
Der Hintergrund ist natürlich, dass sie einfach nicht rausrücken wollen und auch nicht werden. Und es ist eben, also diese diese immer wieder neuen ähm,
Verweigerung, ja? Der Bundesregierung an dieser Aufklärung,
irgendwie mitzuhelfen. Ähm nähren natürlich auch hier diesen Eindruck ähm,
dass die inzwischen halt wirklich,
NSA Untersuchungsausschuss eben inzwischen ein bisschen unangenehm wird, ne?
Dass sie jetzt sagen, okay, nein, meine Güte ist immer noch nicht gelernt, wie ihr euren Scheiß
Ausschuss aus den Medien haltet. Wolltet ihr euch hier streiten oder wollt ihr noch eine Karriere machen? Guck mal, ihr habt da auch Kinder und Haus und so, ne? Muss ja auch abbezahlt werden. Und das wird halt irgendwie jetzt alles da mal so langsam angefahren,
Und dabei war der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, bevor sich jetzt hier der Eindruck äh aufdrängt. Ja, noch nie irgendwie eine besondere Speerspitze der Aufklärungswilligkeit
it, ja? Also das war ja, ne, aber
Selbst da ähm wird es jetzt langsam einfach zu bunt und er kriegt halt von allen Seiten gesagt, äh haltet mal euch ihr bitte äh zurück.
Jetzt wird hier Kaffee gekocht.
Ja, muss, muss sein.
Sein, da möchte ich aber auch einen.
Wird's auch einen. Mit Milch? Ja. Okay. Küsse.
Und ein bisschen Zucker. Aber es hier ist hier Kapselkaffee, ne? Magst du den?
Kaffee unterhalten oder über die Zukunft des.
Wir haben jetzt schon über autonome Fahrzeuge gesprochen.
Ja, wir schweifen ab.
Von Kaffee hast du auch keine Ahnung, wenn ich mir die Maschine habe? Nein, okay, Entschuldigung. Das ist hier eine äh Nes Nespresso, ne.
Ja, das ist äh so Junk, der irgendwie ganz praktisch ist, wenn man sich hier keine voll ausgestattete Maschine leisten will. Aber wir sind jetzt im falschen Podcast.
Es stimmt, wir sind heute aber das ähm also ähm weil ich heute so hier reingestürmt bin und der Tim ähm.
Zu spät gekommen bist.
Ich bin zu spät gekommen und der Tim war schon zu früh da und ich muss auch früh wieder gehen und der Tim hat eigentlich gar keine Zeit. Deswegen hatten wir gar keine Zeit fürs Vorgespräch und streuen das Vorgespräch jetzt hier so ein bisschen mit ein in die Sendung. Das kann man aber auch mal machen, Tim, das ist jetzt auch nicht so schlimm.
Wissen die Leute endlich, worüber wir uns vorher unterhalten. Ganz banale Sachen,
eine Entzauberung dieses Formates mit. Ist ja wohl klar.
Ja. Ähm,
Wusstest du schon, Tim übrigens, wo du dann noch an der Kaffeemaschine bist? Die Praktiken des äh GCHQ verstoßen nicht gegen die Menschenrechte. Ja.
Ach. Das ist jetzt. Wer denn?
Haben sie rausgefunden, dass investige Torry Power Stripional.
Wo gehört das denn hin?
Ähm das ist eine, das ist eine ähm eine juristische eine juristische Körperschaft des Vereinigten Königreiches, die ist unabhängig von der britischen Regierung,
Und ähm.
Ist die nicht unabhängig?
Steht jetzt hier nicht. Das ist sehr geil. Das ist also dort werden,
Beschwerden, über Überwachung angehört, ja? Und,
Das einzige Tribunal an das Beschwerden über die Geheimdienste,
herangeführt werden können. Und das wurde im Jahre zweitausend durch den Investor-Gutori,
PowerSact oder die Regular Regulation of Investicutory Powers Act äh ins Leben gerufen.
Ja, seit zweitausend gibt's das. Man weiß aber nicht genau wo. Denn die Investigutory Power Stripinal des Norddisclose it's adress.
Also sie geben, sie verraten nicht ihre Adresse, aber sie haben ein Postfach.
Briefkastenfirma ist das.
Sie haben einen Briefkasten in äh nein Ernst landen in der Nähe des äh Secret Intelligence Buildings.
Investigative Briefkastenfirma.
Ja. Na ja, ist ein äh ein ein Tribunal, ne. Und die kümmern sich halt um
und
und ähm da sind dann irgendwie so ein paar Leute drin und so, ne. Also es ist schon ganz, ganz lustig. Die haben äh so im Jahr irgendwas zwischen sechsundsechzig und hundertsechzig Beschwerden, mit denen sie sich auseinandersetzen,
Unter anderem jetzt irgendwie eine äh bezüglich des äh GCAQ und diese konzentrierte sich insbesondere auf die Fernschaltung von Mikrofon und Webcam an äh unseren Computern,
Und äh bezog sich auf den
Massenzugriff durch ja? Also das waren die Dinge wo man sich jetzt ausmalte die besten Möglichkeiten oder die besten Chancen bei einer Beschwerde vor dem Investigutory Powerstrivial zu haben,
Und das sagte ja, dieses dieses, dass man erstmal ähm.
Ja, wie nennt man äh,
Ja, wir haben während der so einen schönen, wie heißt das denn auf Deutsch mit mit dem äh Schleppnetz? Wenn man erstmal Schleppnetz fischt, ähm,
dass und zwar ohne ihr, also ohne irgendwelche Unterscheidungen zu treffen, dann könnte das schon ungesetzlich sein.
Aber so wie das der macht, ist es nicht ungesetzlich.
Ah, wieso? Weil die, die schmeißen ja die Delfine wieder ins Wasser oder was?
Genau, weil sie die weil sie die Delphine grob rausschneiden, uns wieder ins Wasser werfen. Äh also es ging um ihre Praxis beim Auswählen,
und aufbewahren von abgefischtem Material, ja?
Das heißt, sie sagen also, naja, die können, die fischen halt einmal durch und dann werfen sie halt einen, einen Teil davon wieder weg und deswegen sammeln sie ja nicht alles. Das ist genau diese Argumentation mit dem ah, ähm.
Ihr hängt überall dran, ihr zeichnet auch äh automatisch eigentlich mit Hilfe von Computern jeden Telefonanruf auf, aber ihr analysiert ihn ja mit Hilfe eines Computers,
und markiert ihn dann als ähm relevant oder irrelevant
und deswegen überwacht ihr ja nicht alle, weil das ja Roboter für euch tun. Ja, also so ungefähr ist hier die, die Argumentation, dass sie sagen, nö, nee, das ist schon gesetzlich. Ähm,
Es könnte ungesetzlich sein, da habt ihr recht, das ist schon in Ordnung, dass ihr hier mal nachgefragt habt, aber ähm ne, gehen sie weiter, hier gibt es nichts zu sehen. Danke, Investigutory Power Stripinal. Ähm
Das war die Klage von Amnesty Privacy International und an anderen, die jetzt natürlich sagen, okay, wir gehen jetzt an den,
EuGH an den European Court of Human Rights. Also das jetzt irgendwie äh das ist die Parallele zu dem ähm US-Amerikanischen,
ähm Cord, hm, wie hieß der denn, Sispay war der Act und der Court hieß, meine Güte.
Ja, was jetzt auch gerade nicht mehr auf jeden Fall dieses, diese dieses Geheimgericht, das ist wahrscheinlich auch so etwa dasselbe ähm juristische Modell, was hier dem also zugrunde liegt, nehme ich mal an. Ne, das heißt, man schafft da sozusagen ein Geheimgericht,
über dessen Tätigkeit und Entscheidungen wahrscheinlich auch so primär erstmal nicht so ohne Weiteres äh ähm also,
geredet werden darf. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie stark die Einschränkungen jetzt hier im.
Bei dem IPT, ich mein, das ist natürlich ein Leuchtturm der Transparenz, im Gegensatz zu dem ähm Fisk,
Forentellen im im Gegenzug zu dem Fisk haben sie ja äh eine seit zweitausend bekannte Existenz und ein Postfach,
Ja
Also.
Genau.
Frag mal, wenn ich, wenn ich jetzt hier äh.
Verstehen. Wir wir sind sozusagen der Öffentlichkeit verpflichtet. Wir haben ja ein Postfach.
Ja, das ist, also das ist schon.
Äh in der Tat eigentlich ganz gut, ja.
Also wenn man Fisk Adress googelt, ist der dritte Treffer, der zweite Treffer der Fischmarkt in Hamburg. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die halt auch schön.
Da sind die. Der Fischmarkt, der kam ja immer schon so ein bisschen fishi vor.
Ja, also da Amnesty und Privacy International werden da jetzt äh weitergehen. Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch richtig so.
Ja, ne, ist auch gut. Ich äh hatte schon so kurz das Gefühl, dass meine Menschenrechte verletzt wurden, aber jetzt bin ich beruhigt.
Also für außer Kapsel ist der Kaffee echt in Ordnung.
Ne
Ja, na, da haben wir ja Glück, dass äh äh vor solchen Untersuchungsausschüssen ja dann alles äh die Wahrheit äh dann auch wirklich trotzdem ans Licht kommt irgendwann. Weil natürlich alle gewissenhafte Aussagen machen,
Ne, und dann endlich mal auspacken. Ist jut.
Das ist super. Jetzt war ähm SL da. SL hat auch eine Adresse,
Das ist der Projektleiter für die äh Operation Alconal und ähm er erklärte dann, dass,
Das ähm der BND unter dem internen Namen Granat,
nicht direkt am Dezix äh angesetzt habe, sondern gezielt anhand einer Voranalyse ausgewählte Leitung eines in dessen Umfeld tätigen Netzbetreibers,
Das ist hier genau wieder dieses, ne, anhand einer Fondsanalyse und so weiter. Ähm wir haben sie also mit einem Netzbetreiber zusammengearbeitet und offenbar, so wie sich's jetzt rausstellt, nicht direkt am Dezex gehangen.
Und bei diesen ähm,
im Umfeld des DTX tätigen Netzbetreibers haben sie äh damals ursprünglich zwei Mal fünf Gigabit pro Sekunde äh abgreifen können,
Abgelegt wurden aber natürlich nur äh Teile davon, weil es ist eine Sache irgendwie einen Rechner dahinzustellen, der mit ein paar FPGAs oder so fünf Gigabit pro Sekunde da durchschiebt und grob
mal so vorsortieren kann, aber es ist eine andere äh Sache, die auch wirklich sinnvoll wegzuschreiben.
Ähm das hatten wir, glaube ich, äh hatte ich auch schon öfter mal erklärt, wie das solche Systeme so funktionieren.
Wenn unser Zielprofil, unsere Selektoren und unsere gesamte Prozesskette erfüllt sind, dann werden die Daten eben auch abgelegt. Wohlgemerkt, abgelegt heißt natürlich noch lange nicht, dass ähm,
dass sie äh abgehört wurden jetzt, ne.
Nee, nee, abgelegt. Ausgeleitet.
Abgelegt. Das ist ausgeleitet und abgelegt, aber das ist noch lange kein Überwachungsstaat, Freunde.
B. Hier wird nur ausgeleitet und abgelegt. Ist ja auch, was man so von so einem Beamten noch erwarten würde.
Interessant ist der Andre Hahn,
den wir gerade schon erwähnt hatten, der von der Linken bezeichnete dann an irgendeiner Stelle die Aussagen des Zeugen SL nicht als zutreffend oder als nicht zutreffend. Und Ströbele gab ihm in der Sache recht. Und jetzt siehst du.
Auf welcher Basis äh könnt ihr denn diese Informationen.
Ja äh wir hatten ja in den letzten Wochen schon öfter darüber gesprochen, dass die in dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss sitzen,
dann haben sie immer diese öffentlichen äh Anhörungen und dann die Nicht-Öffentlichen. Und in den aus den nichtöffentlichen dürfen ja nichts verraten, weil die ja geheim sind.
Und jetzt sitzen die also in dieser Situation, dass in der öffentlichen Sitzung jemand etwas erzählt, völlig freimütig für die Presse und alle, die da sitzen.
Aus den Aussagen der nichtöffentlichen Sitzung sozusagen widerspricht.
Ströbele hat das sehr schön formuliert. Er sähe hier ja in den öffentlichen Anhörungen immer wieder Zeugen, deren Aussagen mit den Akteninhalten,
Akteninhalten nicht zu vereinbaren sind. Der hat ja kann man ja nochmal hier für für Folge hundert werben,
kann das ja dann sehr schön äh auf den Punkt bringen.
Genau, verfolge hundert mit zwölf. Christian Ströbele. Hans-Christian und uns.
Und die Opposition konnte aber natürlich,
Ihre Sorge, wo der scheiße labert? Nicht konkretisieren,
Weil das hier Informationen aus der nichtöffentlichen Sitzung waren. Das heißt, der Hahn konnte sich halt hinsetzen und sagen, ja äh sie erzählen Dinge, die sind unwahr,
Und konnte sich wieder hinsetzen, ja und konnte aber nicht sagen, was genau und auf welcher ähm auf welcher Information
Eher diesen Vorwurf begründet. Es ist natürlich klar, dass an dieser Stelle eher dem Andre Hahn und dem Christian Hans-Christian Ströbel dazu glauben ist, als
SL, auch wenn er ein wohlverdienter Projektleiter äh der Operation Alconal ist, der schon mehrere Gigabyte Daten abgelegt hat.
Und ausgeleitet.
Ausgeleitet und haste nicht gesehen, ja. Er sagte dann weiterhin, also SL sagte,
Ja, also einen automatisierten Transfer von Daten gäbe es nicht. Auf keinen Fall von Informationen über Deutsche Grundrechtsträger. Das ist mein neues, ich weiß, den den Begriff hatten wir, glaube ich, schon mal, aber der,
ich bin ein deutscher Grundrechtsträger.
Also der Begriff Rechtsträger war mir ja schon bekannt.
Ich bin ein deutscher Grundrechtsträger,
Das ist geil, ne? Grundrechte, die das war eigentlich mal die Idee von Grundrechten, dass du da jetzt nicht irgendwie Deutscher für sein muss oder so, damit du äh äh so ein Grundrecht hast, ne? Oder Menschen, Menschenrecht, aber ich werde mich jetzt ab jetzt ähm,
Nicht mehr als deutscher Bürger, sondern als deutscher Grundrechtsträger bezeichnen. Das ist was, da kann man stolz drauf sein.
Ja, vor allem du, du hast sie nicht und du musst sie tragen.
Die Lasten auf dir.
Ja, es ist einfach eine Bürde auch irgendwo. Man soll da nicht zu viel von dem. Das ist nicht gut.
Und dann hat er, das ist, das ist so geil, wie die das also das ist ja auch so schön, ne, wie,
Deutscher Grundrechtsträger. Ich bin ein deutscher Gutrechtsträger, Tim, du auch. Freu dich, oder bist, ja, nee, bist du bist du deutscher Grundrechtstrehung? Hast du einen deutschen Pass?
Gute Frage. Nee?
Schwierig, Tim, schwierig.
Aus Grundgesetz ist doch nicht für Deutsch da. So für.
Wir können ja mal den
wir können ja mal den SL fragen, aber für ihn scheint das offensichtlich eine Rolle zu spielen, ob denn die Dartschen eines die Daten, die Daten eines deutschen Grundrechtsträger,
werden nämlich im Rahmen einer mehrstufigen Filterkaskade einschließlich technischer Vorarbeit und betrieblicher Nachsorge ausgesiebt.
Und dann bist du nicht mehr erfasst. Betriebliche Nachsorge. Also wie geil, wie man jedes Thema so so zum zu Langeweile zerreden kann durch und durch so beknackte Begriffe besetzen kann. Das ist wirklich keinem mehr.
Triebliche Nachsorge.
Unglaublich, ne?
Mann, ey. Wir haben nur einen Titel pro Sendung zu vergeben, ja.
Ja, aber es geht, es geht eben auch darum, die müssen halt einen kompletten Skandal langweilig machen, ne?
Es gelingt ihnen allerdings auch.
Und dann äh ähm wurde irgendwie eine halbe Stunde dann unterbrochen, ne? Das war Eklat, ne, Eklat.
Klar im NSA Untersuchungsausschuss, halbstündig wurde es dann für eine halbe Stunde, was dann nicht öffentlich, haben sie sich beraten und dann einigten sich beide Seiten darauf, dass Linke und Grüne den Vorwurf der konkreten Falschaussage fallen ließen.
Was auch immer da wieder da los war. Dann kam noch der Telekom-Chef Kai Uwe Ricke, der ehemalige Telekom-Chef Kaique, der ganz zu Beginn sagte, ja herzlichen Dank, dass sie mich eingeladen. Ich habe im Kern eigentlich nichts zu sagen.
Äh
Also der war bis zweitausend bis Ende zweitausendsechs Vorstandsvorsitzender der Telekom.
Genau und der SL hatte vorhin dann ausgesagt, die Telekom sperrte sich zunächst gegen den Zugriff auf ausländische Telefonverbindungen in Frankfurt. Den Widerstand räumte aber eine Art
Unbedenklichkeitsbeschreibung des Bundeskanzleramtes aus dem Weg, damals noch unter Leitung von Frank-Walter Steinmeier.
Unbedenklichkeitsbescheinigung.
Unbedenklichkeitserklärung gesagt. Beschreib, ne, beschreib.
Beschreibungen. Ähm also eine Unbedenklichkeitsbescheinigung des Bundeskanzleramts, also nach dem Motto sie haben so das Gefühl gehabt, dass das könnte jetzt vielleicht illegal sein und dann hat das Bundeskanzleramt gesagt, so nee, nee, nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Vollkommen unbedenklich.
So nicht. Nee. Ist schon okay. Ist schon okay.
Das hat das hat jetzt das hat jetzt der SL erzählt, ne.
Bescheinigung ausstellen falls du möchtest ja? Ach so.
Habe ich schon. Ich bin der Grundrechtsträger. Ähm schön war,
Das hatte jetzt der SL erzählt, der Typ vom von der Operation, ja? Und Ricke, der zu der Zeit Telekom Schäfer, der wusste von allem nichts,
Der hat, der wusste ja gar nicht, der hatte gar keine Ahnung, was abgeht. Das ist alles hinter seinem Rücken, ist das passiert. Ähm obwohl wiederum den Abgeordneten,
Ein persönliches Schreiben des Bundeskanzleramtes an ihn vorlag. Das heißt, sie hatten diesen Brief da liegen. Ja, jetzt muss aber wohl in der Telekom irgendwann mal dieses so oh Brief, was ist das?
Ach irgendeine Unbedenklichkeits äh Bescheinigung vom Bundeskanzleramt, das müssen wir dem Alten nicht hochreichen, da machen.
Überhaupt Brief. Ich meine, das ist die Telekom. Sind doch nicht die Post. So, wirklich.
Sind die kann doch anrufen. Ja ähm so und dann hatte er noch äh äh woran Ricke sich wohl erinnerte, war Anfang zweitausenddrei ein ähm.
Ist konkret bekannt, was in diesem persönlichen Schreiben steht.
Nein, das ist natürlich geheim. Aber ist ja ungefähr klar, was das war so,
Also der SL hat ja gesagt, es gab einen Unbedenklichkeitsbescheinigung, die äh Abgeordneten haben ein Schreiben des Bundeskanzleramtes vorliegen,
Ulrike sagt, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, ich weiß von gar nix. Ich war irgendwann mal Anfang zweitausenddrei mit dem damaligen BND-Chef August Hanning Abendessen, aber das sei kein besonderes Vergnügen gewesen und ähm außerdem.
Außerdem.
Ähm wäre er ja äh Telekom-Chef gewesen, der wollte einen ja alle treffen und er hatte sich halt gedacht, so muss ich das jetzt auch noch machen. So, da hat er eigentlich keinen Bock drauf gehabt, ne. Und aber dann hat er auch gesagt, wenn er das gewusst hätte, wenn er das gewusst hätte, als,
Telekom. Mit diesen ganzen äh Abhören und so, ne.
Obwohl er dazu einen Brief bekommen hat.
Dann hätte er das ja rechtlich prüfen lassen,
Gut, das Schönste ist, dass er jetzt auf den früheren T-Com-Chef Josef Brauner äh getippt hat. Sie hat gesagt so, also ich habe ihnen ja schon gesagt, ich kann im Kern eigentlich nix sagen. Wenn ich das gewusst hätte, hätte ich's rechtlich prüfen lassen, ich weiß von nichts
Den Brief habe ich nicht bekommen, aber es kann gut sein, dass mein Vorgänger vielleicht weiß, laden sie den nochmal ein,
So das war jetzt so der Auftritt der äh des Telekomchefs Ricke. Und das kann natürlich auch sein, dass das sogar ähm dass das irgendwie den Tatsachen ähm entspricht, denn es kann natürlich sein,
dass diese ganze Praxis eben doch schon sehr viel länger läuft,
Ja, also es kann sein, dass er jetzt einmal dieser äh Herr Ricke eben saß und äh möglichst nix damit zu tun haben wollte,
oder es kann eben sein, dass er vielleicht auch wirklich nichts damit zu tun hatte, weil diese ganze Praxis schon sehr, sehr viel länger lief.
Ja was heißt das? Er hat nichts damit zu tun, wenn er schon ein Schreiben des Bundeskanzleramts bekommt. Also, ich meine, das ist ja wirklich echt haarsträubend.
Hey, du kriegst als Telekomchef durchaus auch mal ein Schreiben vom Bundeskanzleramt, ne, ist jetzt nicht so, als wärst du irgendwie ein kleines, mittelständiges und ständiges Unternehmen.
Nee, klar, aber ich meine, dann liest man sich das doch auch durch. Ist ja nicht so, wie wir hier so Haludriss, die dann irgendwie erstmal die Rechnungen ein paar Monate liegen lassen und sich denkt, wird schon nicht so schlimm sein.
Wenn das Bundeskanzleramt mir eine Rechnung äh schickt, dann zahle ich sofort.
Immer. Immer. Immer.
Immer. Immer. Auf Zahlungsziel. Okay, also SL. Mit Sconto.
Okay, also SL, ja? SL, meint, sie hätten damals zusammengearbeitet mit einem, wie haben sie's so schön formuliert? Im Umfeld des Dezix tätigen Netzbetreibers.
Damit ist aber nicht die Telekom gemeint, ne? Damit sind andere gemeint. Hier geht's jetzt um.
Warum bist du dieser so sicher?
Weil das mit der Telekom ja schon bekannt war eigentlich. Also das mit der Telekom war schon bekannt, dass sie mit der zusammenarbeiten. Das ist ein weiterer,
Und das, worum es jetzt ging, bei der Schuld, da habe ich sie vielleicht nicht genau äh erklärt den Übergang. Worum es jetzt ging, ging es äh um insbesondere die ähm Telefonate äh und ausländischen Telefonverbindungen in Frankfurt.
Ist also etwas anderes, als dieser Dezix. Ähm,
Aspekt. Entschuldigung, habe ich wahrscheinlich nicht ausreichend äh trennscharf hier berichtet. Aber ist auch eigentlich völlig egal, weil du weißt halt nicht, ne?
Ist auf jeden Fall alles sehr flexibler. Umgang mit der Wahrheit und äh den Geschehnissen, wie sie eigentlich gut dokumentiert sind von den Beteiligten, Herren, mit und ohne ausgeschriebenen Namen.
Genau, danke SL. Hast du super gemacht.
Öffentlicher, öffentlich im Ausschuss des Bundestages, äh offensichtlich beweisbar die Unwahrheit behauptet. Das hilft natürlich jetzt auch bei allen weiteren Behauptungen dieser Mann getätigt hat, ne?
Das nächste Mal mit denselben Initialen auftrittst.
Das müsste man eigentlich mal den, nein, das sind ja schon immer unterschiedliche Personen, die da auftreten. Also die haben ja auch unterschiedliche ähm ähm äh Projekte, an denen die arbeiten. Aber könnte man mal Andre fragen, ob der nicht vielleicht auch.
Aber sie sind schon, wenn sie da befragt werden im öffentlichen Ausschuss, sichtbar. Die sitzen da jetzt nicht noch.
Sichtbar, aber du darfst ja nicht fotografieren, deswegen sitzt ja auch immer ein Bulle hinter Andre, damit du nicht damit er den nicht.
Ja gut, aber die haben da jetzt nicht so eine, so eine, so eine, so ein Untersuchungsausschuss, Burka, äh doch.
Milchglasscheibe wie bei Bärbel Schäfer oder.
Ja oder einfach so eine Burka halt.
Nee, habe ich so nicht gehört. Ich habe also die sitzen da, glaube ich, ganz normal oder? Also habe ich jetzt äh von anderen nicht gehört, dass die da irgendwie mit der mitm Käppi oder mit der Burka oder so reingehen.
Oder vielleicht ist das ja auch so wie bei Herzplatte oder so.
Es geht da, also die werden äh darf sie nicht fotografieren. Das ist glaube ich der die Einschränkung. Aber müsste man nochmal fragen.
Gut, aber es gibt da zumindest visuellen Sichtkontakt, sodass wenn jetzt andere also dieselbe Person nochmal kommt, dann würde sie vermutlich auch dieselben Initialen haben.
Würde ich jetzt mal von ausgehen, ja.
Ja, ist doch schon mal was. Man sieht, es wird hier nichts unversucht gelassen, um an den Kern der Wahrheit zu geraten.
Ein wichtiges Thema, das wir ähm vor einigen Monaten äh behandelt haben, damals noch, weil es unter der Bundesnetzagentur lag,
Ähm ist das Thema der Zwangsrouter? Äh wo es darum geht, dass dir dein oder es einige Provider dir nicht,
Die Daten mitteilen, die du die Einwahldaten, die du bräuchtest, um einen anderen Router zu nutzen, als den, den sie dir,
nach Hause liefern. Ähm unter anderem gab's, glaube ich, mal eine Zeit lang bei Alice irgendwie so Einschränkungen, wie viele Nutzer dein WLAN haben darf,
Und dadurch, dass sie dir nicht gesagt haben, ähm welche Einwahldaten dieser Router verwendet, konntest du nicht ohne weiteres einfach einen anderen ähm kaufen.
Ähm oder einen anderen Contest kaufen, aber dann eben nicht nutzen. Ähm,
Dahinter verbirgt sich eine sehr ausführliche Debatte, die wir damals auch ausführlich behandelt haben. Da ist nämlich quasi,
In einem heutigen Router verschiedene Geräte in Einheit gibt, nämlich den den Splitter, das Modem,
dann hinter dem Modem wiederum den den Router, der äh das Ganze irgendwie in einen äh IP
Heimnetz verwandelt
da dran dann vielleicht nochmal eigentlich so ein WLAN dran gepflanzt, beziehungsweise das könnte man auch noch als zugehörig zum Router bezeichnen. Und es ist unklar, an welcher Stelle in diesem Gerät hört jetzt eigentlich
die Hoheit des Netzbetreibers auf. Die Netzbetreiber argumentieren unsere hohe Hoheit hört.
Quasi mit diesem Gerät auf. Das Gerät ist unseres und wenn jemand ein anderes Gerät benutzt, dann ähm,
bringt er, birgt das die Gefahr, dass das unser gesamte Infrastruktur kaputt macht und ähm deswegen haben wir ein Recht darauf
festzulegen, welche Geräte genutzt werden dürfen oder nicht. In dieser Folge, es wäre super, wenn wir die nochmal verlinken, weil wir das sehr ausführlich besprochen hatten. Da hattest du dann auch nochmal den äh Fatap und sowas alles behandelt, wie das nämlich früher bei den Telefonen war. Da durftest du ja auch nicht einfach irgendein Telefon anschließen,
Ähm ähnliche ähnliche Debatte haben wir hier nur eben wiederum mit anderen Hintergedanken,
So, die die Folge würde ich also gerne nochmal verlinken und jetzt hatte das Wirtschaftsministerium schon vor langer Zeit gesagt,
Wir wollen, dass die Bundesnetzagentur sich zum Schutze der Verbraucher,
gegen diese Praxis der Zwangsruuter wendet. Und ähm,
Die Bundesnetzagentur hatte dann mehrere ähm Hörungen und dann konnte es auch schriftlich Stellung nehmen. Das hatten dann auch schon mal äh glaube ich der CCC zusammen mit den Freifunnkern getan oder wer war das nochmal? Nee, das waren an einer.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr genau.
Verschiedene Stellungnahmen und so, in denen dann technisch erklärt wurde, was die Hintergründe sind und natürlich vor allem was die Konsequenzen für den Verbraucherschutz äh einer solchen Entscheidung sind,
Und die ist irgendwie alles immer die Anhörung dann da gemacht. Dann hat sie irgendwann gesagt, na ja,
Liebes äh Wirtschaftsministerium, wir können aber eigentlich nichts machen, weil uns ja die rechtliche Handhaber fehlt.
Und hat das Bundeswirtschaftsministerium gesagt, okay, wenn ihr selbst dafür nicht zu gebrauchen seid, dann äh werden wir noch im Dezember eine entsprechende Änderung des Telekommunikationsgesetzes auf den Weg bringen,
Und in dieser Gesetzesänderung ähm,
den Versuch unterbinden, das Router und Modems,
Teil des Netzes zu definieren und damit dem Nutzer Änderungen,
äh zu äh zu verbieten.
Das wird das ist also eine positive äh eine positive Entwicklung, auf die wir jetzt hier blicken
denn ähm und da hat sich das Wirtschaftsministerium, denke ich, von sehr vernünftigen Argumenten leiden lassen, wo sich vor allem gesagt wurde, diese Geräte sind in der Regel äh
hinsichtlich der Ausstattung nicht auf dem neuesten Stand und vor allem nicht hinsichtlich der Sicherheit. Und die Verbraucher haften aber dennoch dafür, wenn etwas damit schief geht. Der prominenteste Fall ist hier
die ähm,
Vodafone äh oder die bei Vodafone sehr verbreiteten WLAN-Router von Arcadian,
Acadian ist hier der Hersteller. Easybox ist der Name des Gerätes. Äh.
Die Hölle das Teil.
Tausendfach vertrieben von von Vodafone. Die haben was sehr Schönes gemacht. Wenn man diese Geräte auf den Markt bringt, dann müssen die ja ein,
eine ein WLAN haben und möglichst jedes Gerät ein unterschiedliches Passwort. Und die Frage ist jetzt, wie kriege ich's wie kriege ich das als Hersteller hin,
Ähm dass das passiert, ja, dass alle meine Geräte das Gleiche äh ein, ein unterschiedliches Passwort haben, dies ist aber nach dem Knopfdruck auf ähm,
auch wirklich wieder das Gleiche ist. Und ähm
da könnte man natürlich jetzt irgendwie für jedes einzelne Gerät eine äh einen eigenen Teil auf die äh ein eigenes,
Teil mit in den in den Speicher rein braten, wo dieses wo dieses äh wo dieser Netzwerkname und das Passwort drinstehen. Aber tatsächlich ist eine naheliegende und einfache Lösung,
etwas von dem Gerät zu nehmen, was Unique ist, daran eine paar ein paar,
Operationen zu vollführen und daraus dann einfach dieses Kennwort zu errechnen. Und was äh Acadin gemacht hat, ist, sie haben die MAC-Adresse genommen. Denn die ist ähm.
Laut,
in jedem Gerät anders und das ist quasi die Younique Adress deines WLAN Modules in diesem Fall, ja? Und die kannst du dir einfach geben lassen, sagst du Mac Adresse,
durch Algorithmus so und so ersetzte alle Fünfen durch As und mache eine komplizierte äh Operation, die möglichst viel Chaos erzeugt und am Ende haben wir einerseits ähm,
fünf Zahlen, die wir an den äh Wählernamen anhängen und wir haben einen, weiß ich nicht, achtstelliges Passwort, ja. Das hat Acadin gemacht,
und dann ist jemand hingegangen und hat sich angeschaut, wie die,
wie diese Funktion funktioniert, also wie dieses Gerät aus der Mac-Adresse den Namen des Netzes und
das Kennwort zu diesem Netz errechnet, die dann ja auch nachher als Aufkleber hinten auf dem Gerät sind, ne. Also diese, das sind ja die beiden Prozessketten, die du auch übereinbringen musst, dass da irgendwo in deiner Fabrik fahren diese Geräte rum,
an irgendeiner Stelle kriegen den Aufkleber und es war natürlich sehr schön, dass einfach über die MAC-Adresse zu machen.
Ist eine super Idee, wenn nicht aber die Meckadresse auch im verschlüsselten Fall die unterste ähm,
Einheit der Wählern-Kommunikation wäre, die sich nicht verbergen lässt.
Das heißt, wenn man in so einen äh Easy-Box-Netz möchte, dann muss man nur seinen äh WLAN einmal so in den Lausch mal hinmodus bringen und sich dann in anschauen, welche,
da brauchst du nicht mal Wire Shock für. Kannst du irgendwie sowas.
Man die MAC-Adresse, auch wenn das Netz.
Natürlich. Ja, natürlich, klar. Ja, natürlich. Die Verschlüsselung ist auf einem höheren Layer. Die Mackadresse kannst du gar nicht verbergen.
Du geht ja auch nicht, weil sonst müsst ihr, also geht ja gar nicht, sonst müsste dein, dein WLAN-Controller ja mit,
quasi alles entschlüsseln können, um zu verstehen, ob's überhaupt für ihn ist, ja? Also per se kannst du die MAC-Adresse nicht entschlüsseln, nicht verschlüsseln. Ähm weil das eben niedrigstes Layer ist und ähm,
So konntest du also weiß ich, brauchst du nicht mal. Nimmst du irgendwie Eisdammblau oder so was? Oder die normale, zeig mal alle WLANs an, dann steht da schon die MAC-Adresse neben,
Und dann errechnest du dir einfach zu der Meckadresse das Passwort,
Und diese Sicherheitslücke ist halt seit seit Jahren bekannt, seit Jahren sind diese Easyboxen davon betroffen,
Und seit Jahren gibt's kein Update dafür. So, das ist natürlich ein sehr gewichtiges Argument ähm,
dagegen die Nutzer auch noch zu zu Nutzung solcher Geräte zu verpflichten, wenn der Markt ähm bessere Alternativen zur Verfügung stellt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt das beste Argument ist, ist definitiv so ein Bedrohungsszenario, dass der aber auch ohne, dass es ein Zwangsrauter ist. Also, jetzt bei jedem Hersteller hätte passieren können, unabhängig davon, wer ihn dir äh zur Verfügung stellt.
Richtig, aber ein Wirtschaftsministerium ist immer ähm ähm also alles für alle, wo irgendwo Wirtschaft und Markt und sonst was dransteht, sind immer ähm sehr ähm,
Hellhörig auf dem Ohr, wenn es darum geht, dass äh ne der Markt etwas regeln könnte.
Und äh deswegen scheint äh insbesondere dieses Argument an dieser Stelle für dieses äh Publikum der entscheidende Punkt zu sein, während wir natürlich äh gerade in,
der Folge Lokbuchnetz Politik achtzig. Ähm uns über noch sehr viele andere wichtige Aspekte einer solchen,
eines solchen ja solchen Zwangsrouterschaft. Ähm,
auseinandergesetzt haben. Ich fand das nun mal ganz lustig, auch mal eine eine Sicherheitslücke in Ruhe zu erklären. Das mache ich viel zu selten.
Zuletzt glaube ich in der Folge mit Ulf mal gemacht oder so. Na ja egal.
Immer mal wieder durch.
Kommen wir zum letzten Thema. In.
Äh Videos.
Videos, genau. In Großbritannien haben wir ja die äh Schaukelfilter,
auch ein Thema, was schon ausführlich bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik behandelt wurde, dass ähm man beim,
abschließend seines Internetanschlussvertrages ähm seine Provider mitteilen muss, wenn man nicht ähm,
einer automatischen Zensur dieses Anschlusses zum Opfer fallen möchte,
Also per Defold ist, sind diese Anschlüsse zensiert und man muss seinen Provider mitteilen. Ich möchte gerne ähm.
Zensiert werden.
Nicht zensierte Schaukelvideos schauen. Und,
Dann gibt's ja noch das das ein darüber hinausgehendes Problem, dass,
Die Briten ja jetzt auch angefangen haben zu sagen ja und wenn wir schon dabei sind, wenn wir schon diese schönen Schaukelsperren haben, dann können wir uns ja auch nochmal mit äh mit Terrorismus auseinandersetzen.
Und Extremismus und so. Das das wird alles direkt mit weggesperrt. Und diese Filter sind ja per die Foul da und das ist natürlich noch ähm noch sehr viel ähm,
noch sehr viel wirksamer, wenn man sie noch auf andere Seite auf andere Sachen äh ausweitet. Das heißt, in in Großbritannien passiert genau das, was ähm,
Was immer gesagt wurde, wo auch immer eine Filterinfrastruktur gebaut wird, nämlich wenn du das ähm wenn du das machst, dann werden sie missbraucht werden,
oder sie werden aus deiner Kontrolle herausrutschen und das ist bei den britischen Filtern jetzt auch äh geschehen. Ähm,
Wir hatten da schon vor einigen Monaten darüber berichtet, dass die Open Rides Group ja sagt, dass ungefähr zwanzig Prozent,
der Top einhundert Liste der weltweit Webseiten von diesen britischen Filtern gesperrt werden. Insgesamt über dreiundzwanzigtausend Webseiten. Bekannt ist nicht die gesamte Menge der Seiten.
Zwanzig Prozent der top one hundred? Ja. Sollen dreiundzwanzigtausend Webseiten sein.
Nein, insgesamt über dreiundzwanzigtausend und allein in den Top-Run zwanzig.
Ach so. Okay. Ja, ja.
Da ist es ja sehr einfach, ne? Zwanzig Prozent von einhundert sind ungefähr zwanzig.
Was hast du eigentlich studiert?
Habe ich studiert. Ähm.
Hammer, also wie du da auch immer so rausgeschossen kommst mit.
Es ist unglaublich, ne? Ich bin da auch manchmal selber von mir überrascht. Insgesamt über äh dreiundzwanzigtausend Webseiten werden blockiert, die genaue Anzahl oder die genaue Liste, genaue Anzahl kennt man nicht. Vor allem,
scheint er auch nicht ähm hinterlegt zu sein, aus welchem Grund eine Seite dann gesperrt ist. Was wir nur feststellen ist oder feststellten,
Bis dass die Seiten des CCC von zwei Providern in Großbritannien gesperrt werden,
Und so geht es natürlich nicht.
Na ja, hätte mal der CCC nicht so viele Pornos auf seine Webseiten stellen sollen.
Was denn für Pornos? Wir haben keine Pornos. Wir sind Extremisten, klar. Terroristen ohne Frage, ja.
Aber mit Sex haben wir gar nichts zu tun.
So, also der CCC ist äh die Seiten des CCC sind auf dieser Liste gelandet. Bei einigen Providern. Äh nicht bei allen.
Ach das ist dann immer noch Provide ab.
Das ist auch noch Provider abhängig, ja?
Das heißt, es gibt auch nicht irgendwie eine,
Liste, die man auch noch irgendwie angehen könnte, sondern jeder macht das irgendwie so nach gut dünn. Sprich, wir haben jetzt hier im Prinzip schon so einen Zensurregime durch private Unternehmen, die das auf,
irgendeiner Grundlage machen, die vollkommen intransparent und klar nicht definiert et cetera ist.
Richtig. Und sie den CCC damit finanziellen Schaden zufügen, denn auch der Ticketverkauf,
Zum einunddreißig C3 ist gesperrt. Ja. Das wäre, also es ist nur deshalb relevant, weil das eine andere Domain ist,
aber auch der ist bei einigen Providern gesperrt und wir haben dann eine kleine Pressemitteilung geschrieben, wo wir dann mal so gesagt haben, okay, es könnte also jetzt einerseits sein,
dass es sich dabei um Overblocking handelt, ne, dass man eben sagt, wenn wir schon einen Zensurfilter haben, dann ist es besser für unseren Zensurfilter, wenn der zu viele falsche positive hat, die er,
Unrechten, also die er ohne Grund sperrt, als wenn er zu viele falsche negative hat,
die er nicht sperrt, obwohl er es müsste. Ja, also in was heißt, bei einer Seite, wo ich mir nicht sicher bin, was mache ich mit der? Die sperre ich erstmal. Früher später wird sich schon jemand beschweren.
So wie jetzt geschehen.
Schon was drauf geändert, dran geändert? Also.
Habe ich jetzt nicht mehr weiter drauf.
Gab es eine Aussage, welcher Provider das jetzt war? Ähm weil wenn das so Provile abhängig ist, dann müsste man das ja vielleicht auch mal.
Es war, also bei Vodafone war's auch der Vorverkauf bei einem anderen Provider nur die Seite CCC. Ich hab's mir aber nicht gemerkt. Ich könnte das jetzt nochmal raussuchen. Ich weiß aber auch nicht, ob sich das nicht inzwischen schon wieder geändert hat. Ähm.
Zurück zum zu dem Punkt. So ist es jetzt also Overblocking, also sind wir da zum äh zum Kollateralschaden geworden, wobei Kollateral wie die heißen, dass sie auf einer Seite sind,
ein bisschen Latein auch übrigens, ne, nicht nur Mathematik. Ähm ist das jetzt ein ein,
unbeabsichtigter äh Blindgänger, der uns da erwischt hat,
oder ist es ähm ist es vielleicht Absicht, ja? Sind wir vielleicht mit unseren Ansichten, mit der Beteiligung einer unserer Sprecherinnen an Klagen gegen den eventuell Extremisten,
Auch über die über den Grund dieser Blockade gibt es eben keine Auskunft. Wir gehen aber natürlich davon aus, dass sich das irgendwie relativ bald wieder ähm,
geklärt haben wird. In Großbritannien ist man aber schon weiter und macht sich nicht mehr nur Gedanken darüber, ähm was ist mit.
Wen sperrt man alles? Mit diesen Filtern, die man ja freiwillig, wenn man sich als Perverser melden möchte, äh abschalten kann,
sondern was macht man mit denen, die diese Filter abgeschaltet haben, den muss man ja auch irgendwie äh die Sitten äh aufrecht erhalten. Und da gibt es einen sehr schönen,
Media Services Regulations
Act zu Video on demand, der zweitausendvierzehn jetzt erlassen wurde, denn bereits zuvor gab es vom British Board of Film Senses,
Der BBFC.
Ja.
Eine Regulierung für oder eine eine Regel für DVDs und die soll nämlich jetzt auch für Streaming gelten. Und das heißt, es wird verboten,
Das produzieren, äh das auf DVD verkaufen und das Streaming von äh Videos ähm,
bei denen quasi während vor oder nach dem Schaukeln,
oder auch ohne Schaukel im Bild, jemand auf dem Besitz eines anderen sitzt, denn das ist ja verboten,
und gefährlich.
Ebenso ebenso verboten.
Was ist denn mit mit Olympia und irgendwie so griechisch-römisch? Ist da auch vorbei. Ja, ja.
Ich lese jetzt nur die Liste vor, was verboten ist, wenn du jetzt nicht auf falsche Ideen. Ähm,
Äh was wäre jetzt da ein schönes Wort? Also wie nennt man das? Na man darf nicht immer liebe Kinder.
Also man darf jetzt nicht jemanden aufm Gesicht sitzen.
Der andere kriegt dann keine Luft und das ist gefährlich. Ebenso bitte alles, was irgendwie mit Natursekt zu tun hat,
geht auch nicht. Und ähm.
Urinspiele.
Urinspiele gehen nicht? Und ähm,
Ja, da da fällt mir jetzt echt auch was, wie könnte man das denn?
Nicht nicht mit den Genitalien pupsen.
Nee, das ist was anderes, Tim, da äh ähm.
Versuch's ja immer zu beschreiben.
Also weibliche.
Ejakulation. Ah.
Ejakulation. Äh ist auch nicht in Ordnung.
Generell nicht, ne? Also, kommen wir denn da hin?
Wie kommen wir denn dahin, wenn Frauen irgendwie großartige Orgasmen haben? Ja, also ich meine, was was äh ne, stell dir mal die Queen vor, wenn.
Oh Gott, die Bilder. Oh Gott.
Oh Gott. Diese Bilder wirst du nie zu Gesicht bekommen, Tim. Und dafür wirst du eine, davor wirst du geschützt, weil der Queen ab sofort das produzieren solcher Videos, der Vertrieb auf DVD und das Stream.
Das hast du nur davon, Elisabeth. Das war's. Vorbei.
Untersagt ist, ja. Okay.
Naja, weiß der Geier, was die für ihren Lebensabend noch für so Überlebensstrategien dann entworfen hat, ne. Meine liebt sich ja jetzt auch nicht mehr so ungeniert als Green,
Beobachtung.
Ja also aber das ist schon wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr äh skurril, was da äh eben Vereinigten Königreich.
Ja, also das ist also finde ich wirklich also bemerkenswert. Also vor allem, was ich besonders bemerkenswert finde, ist die Tatsache, dass es hier ja noch nicht mal,
eine Zensur im Sinne von, na ja, da habt ihr jetzt was böses gemacht, aber er zeigt's nicht jemandem ihm. Ja, also normalerweise haben wir solche Zensurmaßnahmen in Deutschland zumindest eher die Einschränkung von,
geht hinter den Ladentisch, ja, darf nicht ausgelegt werden, darf nicht öffentlich beworben werden, solche Reglementierung. Und nur in Ausnahmefällen mit überhaupt gar nicht erst erzeugt werden,
dass man hier noch nicht mal Filme machen,
die im Übrigen überall im ganzen Internet problemlos, ja, also ich meine, es gibt ja verschiedene äh Anbieter von Schaukelvideos, wo die äh genannten Praktiken,
Suchkategorien sind und von daher ist das halt alles wirklich total albern.
Das ist albern und da wird äh also alles, wozu das führt, ist natürlich kollateralschaden, ne? Und ähm.
Des Marktes in andere Gebiete.
Aber mit der Sperrung müssen wir mal zurückzugehen, äh also das war ja äh auf die Sperrung der der CCC-Seite. Ähm Fightsharing machen sie, sperren sie natürlich auch schon. Also inzwischen sowas wie ToRin Freak oder so, ähm weil.
Auch.
Ja, Torin Freak wird auch gesperrt, obwohl's da, glaube ich, keine direkten Links gibt.
Rheine Magazine.
Einen Blog oder sowas, ne,
Ähm aber kommt halt horrend vor, ne? Und bist du immer, du bist ja immer besser weg, wenn wenn schon Zensur dann auch richtig, dann machst du besser mehr weg als zu wenig, ne? Also
der der Zensur war pinkeln, sagt man immer nur, wenn du vergessen hast was zu zensieren, aber nicht, wenn du zu viel zensierst, dann ist halt mal kurz groß geschreien, dann sagst du ja, so, ja, man hat's vertan. Es ist ja nur zu eurem Besten.
Ja, wir sollten vielleicht übrigens auch mal eine Seite aufsetzen, wo wir überall schon gesperrt sind, also ich glaube, so in China ist äh Meterebene auch nicht so ganz, aber ich weiß nicht, das Lokbuch Netzpolitik jetzt in Britannien auch schon durch.
Ich muss äh nee, Großbritannien wurde ja äh Lok und Netzpolitik wurde ja noch irgendwo anders ähm äh schon mal zensiert im Ausland, im ähm.
China oder nicht?
Nicht mehr genau aber wir haben noch wir haben noch was sehr viel schöneres denn es gibt tatsächlich noch eine dritte Theorie. Ich hab jetzt gesagt Overblock,
könnte einerseits das sein, äh warum der CCC da zur ähm,
zum Opfer geworden ist. Die zweite ist, weil wir einfach Extremisten sind, ja, weil die unsere Ansichten nicht mehr ähm,
akzeptabel sind.
Für den Mensch strömt, den politischen.
Ne? Aber es es gibt noch die äh es gibt noch eine dritte äh,
ein Drittel Theorie, die auch genannt werden muss, denn es gibt eine es gab eine große Firma namens,
Color Climax Cooperation in Klammern CCC. Das war ein großer dänischer Hersteller äh von Schaukelmagazinen und Filmen mit Sitz in Kopenhagen. Also da,
Ähm,
und war in den siebziger Jahren einer der größten professionellen Anbieter von Kinder und Jugend äh Material in diesem Bereich.
In den siebziger Jahren. Ja, die hatten bestimmt.
Mhm. In Form.
Webseite am.
Form von Magazinen und super Acht Filmen,
Ja, die Color Climax Cooperation ähm irgendwie September zweitausendachtzehn äh wegen gerichtlicher Probleme. Ähm
allen möglichen Kram eingestellt und scheint, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr zu existieren. Aber ne, der äh Vollständigkeit halber sei auch hier die Color Climax Cooperation erwähnt, die noch einen dritten Grund,
gäbe äh oder für einen dritten Grund herhalten könnte, dass der CCC ähm hier den britischen Zensurlisten einiger Provider zum Opfer gefallen.
Ja, was also als Gewerbeeintrag nicht mehr existiert, das existiert immer noch in der Vorstellung des Zensurs. Denn der Zensur kann sich mehr vorstellen, als man.
Wie gesagt, also solche der der Punkt, der hier zu machen ist, ich persönlich glaube nicht unbedingt, dass es ähm,
Jetzt gezielt auf den CCC ging. Das wer auch immer da diese Sperre vorgenommen hat, wirklich
wusste, A, den CCC, den müssen wir sperren, ne? Es kann sein, dass sie gesehen haben, ah, das sind Hacker, ne, da müssen wir aufpassen, sowas, sowas wollen wir sperren, das sind Extremisten, die verklagen unsere Regierung. Das kann alles sein,
aber der Aspekt im Zweifel für den Angeklagten ist, lässt wirft auch kein äh besseres Licht auf Zensur, denn
dass du halt nur Unmengen an Unbeabsichtigten Schaden hast bei solchen Zensureinrichtungen, der,
ist und bleibt äh bestehen,
und der ist äh in in allen diesen ähm Zensurregimes ähm allgegenwärtig.
Und es ist natürlich auch schwierig. Ich meine, das sind Briten, die können keine kein Deutsch, ja. Also sperrst du einfach erst mal die Hälfte des Auslands. Damit hast du auf jeden Fall signifikant weniger Schaukelvideos äh auf deinem
auf deinem Netz, ne? Ist ja auch, muss ja auch überlegen, Netzneutralität und Bandbreite und so, ne.
Damit die Telemedizin Medizin sich da noch an den Schaukeln.
Telemedizin. Für die Leute, die halb ersticken, bei denen die Leute aufm Gesicht gesessen haben, weißt du, wenn die dann nachher nicht operiert werden können, weil so, ne, so wird da alles, Mann.
Oh Gott, das ist so absurd. Und dabei ist irgendwie wahrscheinlich sind wahrscheinlich diese Schaukelvideos, die einzig wirklich wahre Telemedizin.
Ich würde auch sagen, dass sie wahrscheinlich eine ganze Menge.
Verhindernde Menge.
Die verhindern eine Menge.
Hm? Wir kommen zum Ende. Aber kein Ende ohne Dank.
Der kommt zum Ende, ja. Eine eine alberne Sendung, jetzt wird man uns wieder vorwerfen, dass wir das alles nicht mit den notwendigen Ernsthaftigkeit behandeln. Aber ist egal.
Mhm. Aber ist egal. Besser als kein Humor.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob wir jetzt hier besonders großartigen Humor äh unter Beweis gestellt.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, großartigen Humor. Ich habe gesagt, Humor.
Humor. Ich möchte an dieser Stelle dann noch die Gelegenheit nutzen ähm dem guten Bernd zu danken,
Der gute Bernd, es gibt ja auch den schlechten Bernd, den.
Mit dem nichts zu tun haben.
In dunklen Seiten des Internets äh sehr viel schreibt. Ähm aber es gibt den guten Bernd und der gute Bernd ähm,
ist auch zum zum wiederholten Male aufgefallen durch besonderes, äh besonderes, unterstützendes Logbuch Netzpolitik, äh für das ihm an dieser Stelle nochmal sehr herzlich
gedankt sei.
Genau, wie auch allen anderen Hörern, die Netzpolitik unterstützen über äh Flatter, über Erwähnungen, ja, also überhaupt mal,
bloggt doch mal,
schreibt doch mal, twittert doch mal, wenn euch Politik gefällt, es gibt bestimmt auch noch andere Leute, die äh hier auch gerne nochmal reinhören wollen, aber irgendwie noch nichts davon gehört haben.
Zum Beispiel so Leute, die Computerspiele spielen
Mindcraft oder so, da kann man ja, da gibt's wenig Sound, habe ich jetzt gesehen. Da kann man nebenbei Podcasts hören, Leute, die viel Auto fahren, Leute, die viel fliegen. Leute, die viel zu Hause sitzen, gar nichts zu tun haben
ähm oder Leute, die vielleicht zu viel Musik gehört haben, das gar nicht mehr mögen,
Jetzt was anderes hören wollen, Leute, die in der Beschaffungskriminalität gelandet sind als ähm Sammler von von Hörbüchern, so bin ich ja an ähm
Am Podcast geraten. Also ich bin dann irgendwann in die Beschaffungskriminalität abgeglichen. Äh und das äh musste dann Hörbücher runterladen. Ist auch gefährlich.
Ja? Und da kann man natürlich dann auch sich einfach, sage ich mal, auch so das so das,
dann geben, ne? Ist legal, knallt auch und man bleibt irgendwie arbeitsfähig und kommt nicht in den Knast so. Das ist halt so Lokbuchnetzkritik,
Hörbuch-Junkies ähm unsere Hörer sind sehr jung, ne? Also die älteren Leute, die sich irgendwie nicht entscheiden können zwischen,
aus dem Fenster schauen und auf den Fernseher schauen, die können ja aus dem Fenster schauen und Podcasts hören. Also da gibt's wirklich relativ viele hm noch äh erschlossene Märkte,
die wir jetzt einfach für zweitausendfünfzehn dann auch auf der Roadmap haben.
Interne Strategiegespräch oder sind wir noch beim Abschluss unserer Sendung.
Ach du nimmst das noch auf.
Ja, ich würde sagen, ihr könnt doch einfach mal,
all die Leute um euch herum, die mit dem Denken noch nicht komplett abgeschlossen haben, einfach auch mal auf diese Spur führen. Ansonsten könnt ihr aber auch einfach nur weiter zuhören und ähm,
euern Teil denken. Vielleicht auf den Kongress kommen, wäre auch ganz gut.
Ja Vorverkaufsschiefer ist Schließwald, ne?
Ja und äh was nicht heißt, dass man da nicht vor Ort auch noch Tickets bekäme, aber der Vorverkauf als solcher, der einen da sozusagen ganz sicher stellt und der auch, sagen wir mal, für den Club gut ist, weil dann kommt die Kohle halt früher rein,
der läuft halt jetzt noch ein bisschen,
mal schauen, vielleicht gibt's nächste Woche nochmal einen exklusiveren Blick auf das Geschehen beim Kongress und inwiefern sich Lokbuch Netzpolitik vor Ort materialisiert, da wissen wir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so richtig.
Du bist ja die ganze Zeit nur mit deiner äh Sendezentrum beschäftigt. Und ähm.
Ist bestimmt auch mit einigen Beschäftigter.
Ich mache dieses Jahr nur den Jahresrückblick. Ich habe extra keinen Vortrag eingereicht.
Na dann haben wir ja noch Potential.
Ja, weil weil es noch nicht so viele gute andere gab und ich gesagt habe, in dieser Konkurrenz sehe ich mich dieses Jahr nicht.
Dann äh denken wir uns noch ein bisschen was aus, überraschen euch alle und wir sehen uns bald.
Bis bald, ciao, ciao.